I've got for you today a true identity
politics fail for you which is really
just a good illustration for why
political arguments and debates that are
based on the participants actual or
perceived identities are so problematic
and I've been lobbying the left not to
engage in them period because there's
just no upside this one has to do with
David Webb who's truly a horrible
right-wing tea partyer with deplorable
politics I mean really a a the term
enemy is a very polarizing term but
really an enemy of everything that
progressives hold dear and value and
fight for and David Webb's been around
for a little while now I think maybe
since at least in the political
landscape since 2010 when the Tea Party
Movement really got going and he has a
show on Sirius XM radio he was
interviewing a legal analyst named ariva
Martin and this was a radio interview
Arriva was on the phone not in the same
room as David Webb and at a certain
point during this interview ariva Martin
claims that David Webb has been able to
obtain the position he has in media as a
host of Serious XM Radio on Sirius XM
radio because of David Webb's white
privilege and of course the problem with
that is that David Webb is a black man
and he mentions this and it becomes just
a completely cringe-worthy incident that
I want to listen to with you right now
I've chosen to cross different parts of
the media world done the work so that
I'm qualified to be in each one I never
considered my color the issue I
considered my qualifications the issue
well David you know that that's a whole
nother long conversation about white
privilege and things that you have the
privilege of doing that of people of
color don't have the privilege of how do
I have the privilege of white privilege
David by virtue of being a white male
you have white privilege with this whole
long conversation I don't have time
Arriva I hate to break it to you but you
should have been better prepped I'm
black
okay then I say you went to White
Privilege this is the fall suit in this
you went immediately with an assumption
your people obviously or you didn't look
you're talking to a black man who
started out in rock radio in Boston this
is the real problem with identity
politics okay is White Privilege real in
the United States of course it is should
we talk about white privilege absolutely
but when you accuse a specific person of
holding a position uh a position in
society in this case David Webb's job or
a political opinion because of their
privilege you instantly lose because now
even it think about what she's saying
she happened to be wrong about him
having white privilege because he's not
white but what's implicit in this entire
thing is that if he had been white his
particular success would be specifically
attributable to White Privilege and then
you've got to get into a debate about
that what are you going to win by
demonstrating that because you're
ultimately not going to be able to do
that Beyond any kind of doubt this is
like telling a person that you perceive
to be gay or straight that their view on
gay rights is merely because they are
gay or because they are straight and
then they say no actually I'm the other
thing right if you say well you only
have that view because you're gay and
the person says actually actually I'm
straight and this happens often with
anti-gay activists and when we used to
interview more of them on the show it
would happen to me I would be
interviewing some homophobe
um and they would say David you have
that view because you're a gay man and
as soon as I say no I'm not I'm a
straight Ally they immediately implode
and the argument goes in the trash David
Webb is a horrible right winger I mean
truly his views are deplorable the Tea
Party is horrifying there's so much to
criticize you lose from the get-go when
you say you have white privilege to a
black guy and this is not a disagreement
over whether White Privilege exists it
sounds like a Reva Martin thinks White
Privilege is real and I believe that
white privilege is real in the United
States this is about the absolutely
bone-headed way in which she claimed a
black guy has a radio show because of
his white privilege and it points to the
same problem that I mentioned earlier if
he had the same career but were white
she would have felt Justified that he in
particular has his job because of white
privilege and that's non-defeasible like
how can you prove to her that that's not
the case it was short-circuited here
because he happens to be black and the
argument could not possibly be right in
this case but here's the real issue that
comes up David Webb is black and
therefore doesn't have white privilege
but Webb also doesn't believe White
Privilege exists Pat and that's where
he's wrong Arriva Martin face planted
with her comment David Webb's view that
white privilege doesn't exist is now
reinforced because she failed so
miserably and that's why this is so
destructive yeah always argue the merits
because you don't necessarily know what
the identity of the person that you're
talking to is like many people don't
know that you're culturally Hispanic for
example uh race that's generally easy to
tell but if you're having a conversation
over the phone you may not be able to so
if you want to bring up identity as
maybe like a secondary or tertiary Point
that's all well and good you can discuss
that as a footnote but it should not be
the primary conversation you're having
argue the merits
in particular because the discussion
about white privilege
can't be about David Webb no matter what
is racist right it needs to be a case
that you can make regardless of the race
of the person you're speaking to it's
really just horrible and I know that
people are going to say David you
shouldn't be giving this any attention
because now right-wing media is going to
run with it now right-wing media already
ran with it I'm giving you this as an
example of how white privilege shouldn't
be used politically as something you
accuse individuals of having this is a
dumb mistake about one person's White
Privilege but it completely destroys a
lot of the standing that the left has to
point out the real issues with white
privilege which have nothing to do with
David Webb in particular